Keith I understand you had distribution
for Mason brothers during production
right um pre-sales deal with my
distributor prior to so I wrote the
script and let's see was November of
2015 and then shortly afterwards at a
pre-sales deal with my distributor so I
had before we started filming I had
distribution already locked in so I was
very fortunate with that and so please
tell us because we have so many
filmmakers trying to figure out how to
get distribution I mean how did you even
get the conversation started with
distributors was this the first one you
talked to um you know people gasp man
well for I think so I met my distributor
I met form I remember because I go to
American film market every year which
most people should go if you're in the
industry and you're always meeting when
you're there it's like a big madhouse of
distributors and you know a financial
everyone's just he just like multiple
floors in Santa Monica at the Lowe's I
think it's the Loews Hotel but I just
met so many different tributes to there
and I stay in contact or email and I
think I was in touch with my distributor
after that from I remember I'm not wrong
um so I just kind of we I think they
reached out to me or I reached out to
them shortly after like months later and
then we started talking and then I told
them that you know I had this feature
film that I was shooting in the summer
of 2016 and then we talked about a deal
and then we end up negotiating locked in
a deal so it was pretty exciting to have
that going into the two or it's a
principal photography shooting
production that was good to have that on
the table so you you came to LA in 2012
10 12 years okay yeah and so then was
this your first AFM was in like what
2015 run there 2015 maybe Gen 14 okay 15
or 14 around there I've been there a
couple years now like two or three years
have been there
oh okay zulan was this your second time
when you I believe so yes okay so maybe
you felt more at ease and then when you
when you went I mean like what what was
your mindset to just start talking to
people and find out who's the
distributor and they're just Tom about
you know right now I'm just networking
allows industry like like I've told
people for I mean 99% was relationships
and networking meeting people and uh you
know people who want to work with you
and you want to work with them so my
goal was just going there and meeting as
many people I can in distributors and
who I would work well with so I ended up
exchanging a lot of cards with people
and talking about the projects I had
with my production company and then then
yeah just stated touch through emails
just constantly emailing people and it's
just a constant hustle so I'm curious
cuz I mean sometimes big events like
that are kind of terrifying are you
going in is it like almost like a bar
like a party situation and then you're
striking up conversations with people
how's that work um kinda not really we
kind of saw them so they have when you
go to American Film Market they have
like I said different levels different
stories of it's like I think like seven
and eight stories high like the hotel
Hotel and every there's every room at
this hotel is a suite obviously they
have different rooms and every
distributors there's distributors in
every single room sometimes even two but
usually a distributor I'll have their
own room or a production company or so
there are type of company investors
people like that so you really just go
around to the different rooms and you
those like there's like a sign-in sheet
you can sign in or you can call or email
their company weeks in advance and make
an appointment and then you can make a
point for you the project you have in
development with you know acquisitions
or or a project was already done what
you're trying to sell you know you just
basically tell them what what you want
and they usually they'll book you for
for appointment if they're interested
and then afterwards usually they close
down like 6:00 p.m. and then you have
everyone goes down it's like the bar
afterwards and that's really where a lot
of negotiations you get over a drink so
it's a good great event I think
everybody and then if you should go if
your producer especially if you're a
director writer actor or anything you
should go it's a must you have to pay an
admission fee right okay sounds like
it's definitely worth it it's worth it
yeah so when you went that one time how
many cards would you say you got from
distributors
- um I would say made close to 100 made
less when they I'm in exaggerated made
like 50 or so long I had like a huge bag
full of just like dozens dozens of cards
you're like going through trying to
memorize who you talk to and stuff so
but a lot yeah it's definitely
interesting okay so then you get home
and are you emailing them how is this
what happens once you have this bag of
cards um well both um so you're you're
flowing up with the people that you
talked to based on whatever your
conversation was on if they like the
project or wait if you're trying to sell
something or it gets your project
development looking for financing
however there are there's there's some
guys would like for just email me if
they say hey you talked about that film
you know we're interested in that let us
know you said you're shooting it in over
the summertime you know we'd be
interested in industry reading it if you
want to talk about that so it's a little
to both but mostly you it's kind of in
your hands you know it's your own you
have to reach out to them along cuz they
have so many people that are talking to
them unless they really love your
project or whatever you're trying to you
know pitch or you or you're shooting see
own that day uh they want to take on
interesting and so then how many of them
said can we see the script like at what
point or did some get back to you some
not get back to you than some psychosis
I mean some did um some did a lot more
more interested in hey you know
Wednesday when's the shoot scheduled
when will you be done and you know
what's the story he was attached really
they really wanna know who's attached
that's the first question I asked is
who's attached what actors what director
what producers cause you know a lot of
people you know industry it's you sell a
movie usually based on the actors in the
talent are attached or sometimes the
director if it's a big-name director
usually named talent so that's the first
question has is who's attached what
actors so that's that and we almost a
story about when you're shooting it when
it will be done things like that and
they will have to script you know
afterwards but
that's great so so you're following up
or they're contacting you and then you
actually shoot the film and then when
you go to follow up with those various
people how many actually follow through
with what you and the films done yeah so
we shall if I'm understanding it's
Crowley so you then you shot the film
and then you're like hey guys you know
to these different as tribute errs right
I'm done you guys want to take a look at
it or right well you can't yes you can
do that obviously and I mean ain't your
question got a lot of from my other
friends with an industry of directors
and other producers and people in that
nature if you have a finished product
and if it if if the picture looks good
they're gonna wanna see a trailer
obviously in a key are at a poster and
if they like that I mean most
distributors if it looks good sounds
good they're gonna be interested
somebody will be interested in if
there's not a key actor semi-attached
however with with my film since I
already had that pre-sales deal with my
distributor prior to shooting I didn't
do that because I already had that
locked in so like when the film was
already kind of contract with them
before shooting so basically once the
film was done you know the film goes to
them they take it for service and for
resale
so that's kind of how that worked with
me so I wasn't doing like all these
emails with that the feature I just did
okay
sorry yeah I was trying to understand
though that's fascinating so this is
your first feature and you're already
locking in a distribution deal before
it's shot right yeah pretty amazing it
is yeah it's I was fortunate it's it's
very hard to get distribution it's very
very hard it's already a distribution
and in financing for a film in general
so like making making a film and pushing
it through to its final ending and
getting out to a distributor and
marketing and stuff is extremely hard
and I'm very fortunate to get to that I
mean it's it was tough so but yeah
that's what happens let me see if I
understand this key so you said that
your distributor wanted you to have
named talent attached how did you prove
to them that you had different people
attached and who were these people
what were the credits right so I mean um
I had a great cast at it
cast members attached well we're in like
a lot of day roles and TV shows and
stuff and wanna June Cesario was in
Sunset Beach back in the nineties and
some good stuff and I had him and then
what really sold my distributor on
taking on the film form I remember was
my my scimitar fur or a Webber he is
2010 he won a well he was part of a
short film 2010 what call it American
promise I believe was called what won a
cabin award and oscar has a 10 and he
was this Emmitt Agra firaon the film
director of photography and like his is
real was awesome
he's real was awesome his raise it was a
resume was awesome and just all that
together I think is what sold them on to
getting that pre-sales deal done but I
think a lot of it had to do with her
role being part of the oscar-winning
movie 2010 a short film what really sold
on to them coming on board and like I
said I had good cast members but we're
in day roles and TV shows and stuff and
then my music composers my opinion the
best in the business are one of the best
Federico Bayona you know he was attached
and he's awesome till now I know you've
done shorts before on your own did they
ask to see those as well so they could
see your other work on it yes yes
absolutely yes I mean they sold my my
resume I gave him my resume and I'm DB
and stuff and then they asked they asked
for my shorts yes
so I got to see my style from directing
as a writer as well so I think all that
all those things in totality as a total
package is what helped keep the deal by
Noel Webber was a big influence as well
since he was part of that movie it says
intent on winning Oscars huge or being
part of film won Oscar so going back to
American Film Market if you were to go
again today or go again for the first
time is there anything you would do
differently um yes I mean I would come
more with the more the packaged film I
mean even when I was going with like the
Mason brothers to American film arc and
I had other projects it wasn't just that
woman
um a little more green in the business I
mean I didn't know as much about come
with more of a complete package more
people attached I didn't have all these
different cast members attached even
that American film market I had some but
as time went on and then when I find so
spoke to my distributor I had more
people attached but I would come more
with a prepared package especially with
just more more names and more people
just to show them this is what it is so
that and then yeah then obviously ready
to show any type of proof of financing
that they can see I mean I want to have
it right there at the market but you
know it's rated if they want to see
where's the proof of financing that you
have to shoot this so we can do a deal
you know within the next week or two
you